hey guys Pete here this will be my is
varus a Targaryen video I had this idea
come up when researching my tourney at
Harrenhal video and then again while I
was working on a new prophecy video that
I'm doing so I just decided to look into
this a little bit today
this theories been around for a few
years and while it might not be true
just like any other theory there is some
interesting stuff to think about did a
quick search before I started to write
the script and found a popular video
that has a similar theory but that
youtuber came up with a different
conclusion where Varys is a Blackfyre so
it's not exactly the same either right
let's get right into it we all know
Varys says the eunuch who is the master
of whisperers on the small Council in
King's Landing the master of whisperers
basically spies for the king and Varys
has held this position since the reign
of the Mad King Aerys before Robert's
rebellion we also know that he helped
Tyrion escape Westeros after he was
sentenced to death and the storyline
changes in the books and the TV show at
that point I'm not going to get into the
differences in this video because it
would take way too much time but in both
storylines he seems to be motivated by
the idea of a Targaryen restoration to
the throne or more probably putting a
black fire in power in the books Farris
has an interesting backstory in which he
rises to a position of power out of
nowhere
grand maester pycelle says the Barrows
was born a slave and lease but Varys
himself says he was orphaned and
apprenticed to a traveling troupe of
mummers who frequented the Free Cities
and at times performed in King's Landing
or Old Town during their stay in the
free city of mirror man offered a large
sum of money for beerus and offer his
master found too tempting to refuse the
man gave Varys a potion that made him
powerless to move or speak but didn't
actually dull his senses and then cut
off his manhood he then burn it in a
brazier and a blood magic ritual beerus
claims to have held hatred for all
things magical ever since when i was
working on the prophecy video i
rewatched the scene in season 6 with kim
bara and marine and in this exchange
between them stood out take what
happened to You Lord Varys when you
original
if not for your mutilation at the end of
a second-rate sorcerer you wouldn't be
here helping the Lord's Chosen bring his
light into the world knowledge has made
you powerful but there's still so much
you don't know do you remember what you
heard that night when the sorcerer
tossed your parts in the fire you heard
a voice call out from the flames do you
remember after the sorcerer was finished
with him he threw varus out in the
streets and by then the mummer's had
already left town so he had to resort to
begging and stealing to survive and soon
became a top-notch thief he eventually
heads to Pentos where he meets up with
Illyrio and the two become rich as a
result of varus his skills as a thief
eventually they realized that stealing
secrets was more valuable than anything
else and beerus started training his
little birds so they could aid him in
their plotting as mentioned Bharath came
to King's Landing to serve the Mad King
Aerys after the fine said dusk and ale
when the King had really reached the
height of his paranoia the King didn't
trust anyone in Westeros so he brought
Barisan to serve as his spy master none
of that makes him a Targaryen though so
what the hell is this video actually
about well there's does a lot of
inexplicable things and he always says
his motivation is for the good of the
realm but if you really look into some
of the things he does especially in the
books it's really hard to follow and it
just doesn't make a whole lot of sense
well his loyalty is questionable towards
the houses Baratheon and Lannister yeah
he was actually loyal to King Aerys he
alerted him about the supposed plot that
the crown prince set up to get rid of
him by calling a council at Harrenhal
and he warned Aerys not to let time and
Lannister enter the city during Robert's
rebellion again that's not evidence so
let's look at what we actually have
by all accounts Varys is born in lys it
just so happens that aerion brightflame
Targaryen was exiled there in the year
208 where he fathered at least one child
in 232 Aryan drank wildfire and died in
233 King makar the first died the Great
Council was called the determined
succession the two eldest sons including
Arian were already dead so the council
noted that Aryan left behind an infant
son but they
ass on the idea of offering him the
crown because he was born outside of
Westeros and he was a bastard instead
they offered to crown maester aemon who
refused it and then the crown went with
King Aegon v who was known as King Aegon
the unlikely in 243 the Mad King Aerys
was born in 248 Aryans bastard son would
have been 16 and that's about the normal
time whenever people start to have kids
in you know in Westeros and Essos and
this is probably one Varys could have
been born in 259 Prince Rhaegar was born
276 King Aerys summons Varys to court to
become a spymaster
if he was born in the rage between
Harrison Rhaegar that would have put a
Barisan around his mid-20s 282 through
283 was Robert's rebellion and that's
when most Targaryen sky and 300 which is
around present time that would mean that
Varys is around his early 50s so the
timing really kind of makes sense but
you have to believe that you know Aryan
was his grandfather one thing that the
Kim Barra Singh made me think about and
something that the original poster
brought up in relation to this theory is
that the sorcerer bought him to use in a
blood magic ritual this could be an
indication that he has Kings blood which
is something that Melisandre is always
looking forward to using her own rituals
and that's our main you know that's our
main reference for blood blood magic
rituals I know it's a lot of
circumstantial evidence but it would
answer some questions related to his
mysterious motives what impact is going
to have going forward doesn't seem that
important as far as the show is
concerned since he's already backing
Daenerys but why don't you guys tell me
in the comments what you think I mean it
opens some doors and I think the
timeline at least makes it possible and
another thing is with aerion brightflame
we learned about his exile and talese
and later works so it's definitely
possible that it was thrown in there by
george RR martin for that reason not to
mention the name Varys looks a little
Targaryen in the first place I mean if
you just add an e in there then you're
all set but that's not obviously good
evidence I'll put a link in the
description so you can find the original
writer thread to check it out the one
big problem with the idea is
varys sent assassins after Daenerys and
honestly I don't have a good answer for
that we know in the books he has someone
else he's trying to put on the throne
but the show doesn't even have that
character and it still doesn't really
make sense he would still want to
protect to protect her most likely so I
really don't know if you have an idea go
ahead and post it in the comments please
like the video if you think it's an
interesting theory and definitely let me
know your thoughts in the comments do me
a favor and subscribe to my channel and
check back for more Game of Thrones
related videos in the near future thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon